TURN RIGHT we said that was your Stinney
term times n minus one lots of your
color ratio okay so therefore if I'm
working out the hub of the first in
terms I start with the first to go to my
second one go the one after that
and now before I finished with the very
last term I'm just going to have a
couple more terms there as well because
a pattern will become obvious which is
actually a very similar strategy to what
we use for the AP okay so if a R to the
N minus one is where I'm finishing up
what would be their really previous term
yeah so you'll be one less than more of
common ratio right a nice - and I guess
that make up reason for that a straight
okay now my goal is to get a serve you
know the Sun in terms of something less
awkward than that so they go for it I'm
going to try and multiply through by
that common ratio okay because well
that's going to let me do is compare
this line of what I'm going to get the
result and there's gonna be a lot of
overlap just QC wife if I take every
single term and multiply through by the
collision okay for starters I'll turn to
to write a I'll turn to a ours where now
what happens down the end here because I
multiply by one more one of our this
will turn into a are two at most two
very lost that okay no oh yeah by the
way can you see that these two lines are
almost identical I just look at the
right-hand side okay because for
instance this term this term and this
one this one in fact they all line up
with two exceptions this term here has
no parallel in this series and likewise
the a here that also has no parallel is
one away okay so if the difference
everything else is the same therefore if
I subtract one line from the other like
this let's do it this way if I subtract
the second line sorry the first line
from a second okay what will I be left
with well I'm starting with that a right
and then everything else will cancel
okay everything else until here right so
this should be minus a and everything
else in between vanished we contended
that okay now remember what was the goal
the goal is just to find the son without
having to list everything yeah okay so
actually you can see that there's no
much work to actually get to this song I
just have to make it this subject I just
to do a little bit of factorizes right
so if I take the somehow I've got R
minus 1 this is I suppose I could take
an a out of here as well just to make it
look a little neater all right so now I
have just by dividing this up
so now notice okay now you may see in
textbook sometimes written a slightly
different way you might see it written
as instead of that a times one minus you
see in reverse order
you see that the same thing right
because going from this Liberator to
this one it's like x minus one and the
two nominally not is the same so it -
what - welcome attention later on you
see why sometimes I choose this one
and sometimes that one even though
they're really the same thing so that's
the sum of a geometric series
now what this leads us to is really
interesting things like say our example
before we started with was when the
common ratio is 1 right but what if the
common ratio sorry come resume career
shoots - right I'm sorry it's growing
right the terms gonna be whatever the
common ratio is less than 1 what if it's
getting smaller
right like say always instead to say it
was a half now even though it doesn't
seem that intuitive right this sticks
from infinite number of terms right but
actually it's actually equal to a finite
number this thing you can keep on going
and I'll just keep on getting bigger
than or bigger but this thing has what
we call the limiting son there's a point
at which it can't get any further and in
fact this series here is a there's a
riddle based on this series which is
thickness a frog and it's trying to jump
across the room and it's something
reader frog it can only jump half the
distance it sees in front of it right so
leave that one off the front so starts
on one end and then jumps half the
distance and then it's a pathway and it
looks - in the room
that's Bella half the distance which is
a quarter the roof and it keeps on going
right that's what I intuitively think
okay it's probably never going to get to
the end right because it'll always have
a little more to jump okay so that's
what we mean by a limiting some it can't
go on forever right the Frog actually
never gets out the rear so we're going
to go look at some specific examples
with that a bit later on
I'll just content together what's what's
the sum of the whole series and what is
one last thing before we when we were
doing a peas we looked at how do you
prove that something is an AP as opposed
to assuming it or a years and then just
working off its properties okay
so do you remember what was the way we
proved if I gave your sequences or a
series how can you prove that it was
many are we looking for
yeah okay so we want um there'd be a
constant between successive terms so all
I said is for example the third term
mates the second term should be the same
as four separate management first or
generally speaking if I take the n plus
1 term and previous one right that
difference should always hold okay so
that's what we had but it's an AP
because there's a common difference
right how would you prove that
something's a GP
yeah so instead of subtraction I'm going
to use division right so instead of this
minus that I'm gonna say this / yeah
that'll give me the ratio between them
and that ratio should be the same as the
ratio between the previous pair of
numbers in the sequence or what
generally speaking like like this like
PR right if I take the ratio between any
term and the one before it okay
it should be the same in the ratio
between Mattson and the one before that
okay so these are the tests for how to
prove that something is a geometric